[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا مع تطورات العاجله التي
وردت قبل قليل حيث اعلنت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه الاوروبيه انها اضطرت الى اسقاط
طائره مسيره امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود بعد
اعتراضها من قبل مسيرات روسيه وقالت
القياده الامريكيه ان المقاتلات الروسيه
نفذت اعتراضا غير امن للمسيره فوق المياه
الدوليه للبحر الاسود الامر الذي كاد ان
يتسبب في اسقاط مقاتله روسيه والمسيره
الامريكيه التي كانت في مهام معتياديه
مشيره الى انها اضطرت لاسقاط المسيره
تجنبا للحادث
[موسيقى]
بدوره قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
بالبيت الابيض جون كيربي ان الرئيس جو
بايدن على علم اصطدام المقاتله الروسيه
والمسيره الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود وفي
الافاده صحفيه اعتبرها بان اعتراض المقاتل
الروسيه للمسيره كان غير امن وغير احترافي
مضيفا ان المسيره الامريكيه لم تشكل اي
تهديد وكانت تقوم بمهمه في الاجواء
الدوليه واوضح البيت الابيض ان وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه ستبلغ المسؤولين الروس
بمخاوف واشنطن بعد الحادث وشدد كوربي على
ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل خدمه مصالحها
الامنيه في البحر الاسود مشيرا الى ان
واشنطن لا تحتاج الى تنسيق مع روسيا عندما
تقوم بالتحليق فوق البحر الاسود
مزيد من التفاصيل مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من
واشنطن
سابدا من اخر التطورات والتصريحات من هناك
ما هي والى ماذا تنظر
اولا كان من الملاحظ ان جون كوردي عندما
كان يتحدث الى الصحفيين كان يتحدث بلهجه
هادئه جدا وقد تعمد جون كوربي ان لا يذكر
اي كلام حول تصعيد او يوجه اي كلام حول
تهديدات كل ما حاول ان يقوله جونكر به
وكنت استمع اليه عبر الهاتف عندما كان
يتحدث الى الصحفيين كما يقول ان ما فعله
الروس هو عمل غير مهني ويحاول ان يقول
ايضا ان ما كانت تقوم به المسيره
الامريكيه كان امر عادي وكان ايضا في
الاجواء الدوليه وفوق المياه الدوليه
وبالتالي نحن لا نقول هنا ان الامريكيين
فقط لا يريدون التصعيد الامريكيون راوا
هذه الحوادث من قبل عده مرات وهم يتعمدون
بشكل اساسي ان يبتلعوا هذه المشكله الى حد
ما لانها اضرت بمسيره وبالتالي ليس هناك
اي سبب للامريكيين لتصعيد الموقف هناك بعض
التفاصيل التقنيه حول ما حدث مع هذه
المسيره من الضروره للاشاره الى ان بيان
القياده الاوروبيه قال ان الطائرات
الروسيه تعمدت اولا اسقاط انواع من الزيوت
والبنزين على هذه المسيره الامريكيه عندما
لم ينجحوا في اجبارها على السقوط تعمدت
احدى الطائرات الروسيه على ضرب مروحيه هذه
المسيره الامريكيه عند ذلك اضطر
الامريكيون الى انزال هذه الطائره من
الاجواء السبب على الارجح هو ان لا تذهب
هذه الطائره الى الاجواء او المياه
الاقليميه الروسيه وبالتالي يحصل الروس
على تقنيات هذه المسيره يعني
عندها عندما يعني تشير بانه
عمل غير مه
100% معك حق الكلام الامريكي ينم بشكل خاص
على
على وجود اي على عدم وجود اي نيه للتصعيد
بين الطرفين
كان واضح حتى انه
تحدث ببرود حول هذا الموضوع وكان الصحفيون
يسالونه حول قضيه المسيره مره يقول لهم
تحدثوا الى وزاره الدفاع حول التفاصيل
اكثر ومره ثانيه يقول ان وزاره الخارجيه
هي التي سوف تتعاطى في هذه المسافه بيان
اذا يعني امكن قبل ان نختم النشاط
الامريكي فوق البحر الاسود يعني اذا يمكن
ايجازه بالفتره الماضيه وهل يمكن ان يطرا
عليه اي تعديل تحسبا لاي يعني نزاع محتمل
بين الطرفين اذا ما تم تخطي الخطوط الحمر
هناك
هناك تعديل بدون شك منذ ان بدات الحرب في
اوكرانيا عندما امتنع الامريكيون من
التوجه الى بحر ازف
ولان هذا المكان هو مكان عالي الحساسيه
بالنسبه للروس وايضا من الممكن ان يتسبب
بتصعيد ولكن بالنسبه لمنطقه البحر الاسود
هذه منطقه تتحكم بها القوانين الدوليه
الامريكيون تابعوا اعمالهم في هذه المنطقه
بشكل عادي هناك بعض المعلومات التي ظهرت
خلال الساعه الماضيه تقول ان الروس لم
يكونوا راضين ابدا عن الوجود الامريكي في
منطقه البحر الاسود وهم تعمدوا من قبل الى
مشاكسه بعض الطائرات او المسيرات
الامريكيه ولكن يريد الامريكيون القول ان
هذه مياه دوليه وهذه اجواء دوليه ومن حق
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تحلق مثلها
مثل اي طرف اخر في هذه الاجواء اليوميه
شكرا مراسل العربيه حدثنا من واش
نطن
في الحرب الاوكرانيه تتواصل معارك على
الجبهات وفي وقت لا تزال فيه معركه مخموت
غير محسومه تماما وتتحول الى معركه
استنزاف للطرفين الاوكراني والروسي رئيس
فاجنر الذي تقاتل قواته على الخطوط
الاماميه مع الروس قال ان عناصره كلما
اقتربوا من وسط المدينه ازدادت المعارك
قسوه مع استخدام سلاح المدفعيه واوضح ان
قوته تواجه مقاومه شرسه وان الوضع في
مخموت صعب للغايه مضيفا بان الاوكرانيين
يدفعون باحتياطات لا نهايه لها في المعركه
وبالحديث مشاهدينا عن التطورات الميدانيه
في اوكرانيا قال تقرير للصحيفه واشنطن
بوست ان القوه العسكريه لاوكرانيا متدهوره
بعد عام من الحرب اذ تدور الشكوك حول قدره
كياف في شرم هجوم في الربيع المقبل
بين هذه الخطوط والعاصمه كييف يدور شك في
قدره الاخيره على شن هجوم مضاد في الربيع
كما قالت وتتحضر
فعام من الحرب انهت جيشها وافقده الافا من
ذوي الخبره القتاليه
في احدث التقارير الغربيه فان حاله القوه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه متدهوره بسبب حجم
الاصابات التي اخرجت العديد من المقاتلين
الاكثر خبره من ساحه المعركه
يرجع مسؤولون اوروبيون وامريكيون حاله
التدهور هذه لعده اسباب
فخلال عام وقع 120 الف جندي اوكراني بين
قتيل وجريح
جلهم من ذوي الخبره القتاليه
حجم الخساره هذا دفع كييف للدفع بمجندين
عديم الخبره لسد النقص على خطوط القتال
اضافه للنقص الاساسي في الذخيره
وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست فان الاشهر
القادمه تشكل تحديا امام كييف لاستعاده
زمام المبادره وشن هجوم في هذا الوضع الذي
يعاني فيه جيشها من نقص في العدد والعتاد
بالمقابل فان حال الجيش الروسي ليس بافضل
حال وان كان عدده يشكل ثلاثه اضعاف جيش
اوكرانيا
فوفقا للتقديرات الغربيه ذاتها فقد خسرت
موسكو قرابه 200 الف جندي بين قتيل وجريح
اضافه لمشاكل في الذخيره والقوى العامله
وما بين تشكيك بقدره كييف وموسكو على
الهجوم والدفاع فان التقديرات تقول ان
عاما من الحرب انهك الجيشين وان عاما
جديدا بدا لتوهه ايضا بالحديد والنار
هذا وقال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
الغرب راهن بعقوباته على انهيار روسيا في
غضون اسبوعين او ثلاثه بعد العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا واضاف بوتين خلال
لقاء مع العمال في مصنع للطائرات في مدينه
اضاف ان البعض في اشار الغرب اعتقد انه
عندما تغادر الشركات الاجنبيه روسيا كل
شيء سينهار لكن شركات الروسيه حلت مكانها
على حد قوله وشدد بوتين على ان الصراع
بالنسبه لموسكو يعني الحفاظ على وجود
الدوله الروسيه واكد الرئيس الروسي ان
النظام المالي لبلاده صمد بفضل اجراءات
المصرف المركزي وفق تعبيره
وفي شان متصل صوت البرلمان الروسي لصالح
قانون يفرض رقابه واسعه على منتقدي القوات
المسلحه والمتطوعين المشاركين في العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بما في ذلك مجموعه
فاغن وبموجب القوانين الروسيه الحاليه
يمكن ان تصل عقوبه من يدان بتهمه تشويه
سمعه الجيش والمشاركين في العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا الى السجن لسبع
سنوات في حين قد تصل عقوبه نشر معلومات
كاذبه عمدا عن الجيش الى السجن لمده تصل
الى خمسه عشره سنه
[موسيقى]
الى تداعيات انهيار سيليكون فالي وبنوك
اخرى في الولايات المتحده حيث اعلنت wales
ان وزاره العدل وهيئه البورصات في
الولايات المتحده بدات التحقيق رسميا لكشف
ملابسات الانهيار ومحاسبه المتسببين اعلان
ياتي في وقت هدات تحدثت المخاوف من ازمه
شامله في القطاع المصرفي وتحول المستثمرون
الى اسهم البنوك من جديد بعدما تراجعت على
مدار ثلاث جلسات متتاليه الاجراءات التي
اتخذها الفيدرالي والتي كان اهمها ضمان
ودائع بنكي سيليكون فالي وسجنتشر بنك
المتعثرين ساهمت في اعاده بعض الثقل
للقطاع كما ان اطلاق الفيدرالي لبرنامج
التمويل البنكي لاجل بنك تورم فاندين
بروجرام والذي سيقدم قروضا لمؤسسات
الايداع مدعومه بسندات الخزانه الامريكيه
والاوراق الماليه المدعومه بالرهن العقاري
قد ساهم بتهدئه المخاوف ايضا
من جهته اعلن الرئيس التنفيذي الجديد
للكيان الجديد المؤسس تحت شركه التامين
على الودائع الفيدراليه
الذي تم نقل جميع ودائع واصول بنك از في
بي المتعثر اليه اكد اعاده مزاوله الاعمال
داخل الولايات المتحده مشيرا الى ان
الاعمال غير عبر الحدود ستستانف في الايام
المقبله واكد ايضا الرئيس التنفيذي الجديد
ان المذيعين يمكنهم الوصول الى اموالهم
كما ان الودائع الجديده والقائمه محميه
بالكامل
[موسيقى]
في مقابله سابقه مع العربيه اكد نايف
الغيث كبيره الاقتصاديين في بنك الرياض
اكد ان الازمه البنكيه في الولايات
المتحده لا تشكل خطوره على البنوك
السعوديه لافتا الى ان حجم الاصول
الاجنبيه في البنوك السعوديه تشكل اقل من
ثمانيه بالمئه من اجمالي الاصول البنكيه
في المملكه
كلمات علق هل البنوك السعوديه في خطر من
هذا
الوضع العالمي او لا يمكن لها من منظور
حجم الانكشاف الاجنبيه حجم الاصول
الاجنبيه
البنوك السعوديه
تقريبا44 مليار هذي يشكل اقل من ثمانيه
بالمئه من حجم
الاصول في
اصول البنكيه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بس انا بعيد الاصول الاجنبيه ماذا تضم تضم
سندات
امريكيه الان اذا كنا بنفرق الاصول
الاجنبيه تضم فعلا سندات خارج سندات
اجنبيه وتضم
قتال في العصور لكن حجم السندات بشكل عام
السعوديه
اقل من 15% من السند من سندات محليه
وسندات اجنبيه
والاغلب
السندات الموجوده في السعوديه اغلب
ها بشكل اكثر من 13% من من 15%
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من لندن عب
ر للدراسات الاستراتيجيه دكتور اسمح لي ان
ابدا
بمؤشرات
الاسهم عادت للانتعاش اليوم ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني على البنوك وعلى الاسواق الماليه
معناته ان في تفاؤل من قبل المستثمرين
والبنوك على
التدخل البنك الفيدرالي والحكومه
الامريكيه لمحاوله السيطره على هذه الازمه
قبل ان تنتشر الى قطاعات وبنط اخرى
دكتور يعني بمواساه ذلك
الفيدرالي
الامريكي وايضا سلطات الامريكيه تتعهد
اليوم بمحاسبه وبتحقيق كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
هذا التحقيق لبنك من المعروف حتى الساعه
بان ادارته كانت سيئه ان كان بموضوع اعطاء
القروض وان كان بموضوع متابعه البيانات
الماليه ماذا يعني ايضا ما النتائج
المتوقعه من هذا التحقيق وكيف ستنعكس على
اداء البنوك في المرحله المقبله
المشكله لهذا البنك يعني نتكلم على بنك
الاداره ما كانت سيئه مثل ما نتكلم على او
نقارنه مع بنك لي من على سبيل المثال مع
التدخل في المشتقات الماليه المعقده لا
البنك كان يستثمر في سندات الخزان
الامريكيه اامن
الاصول الموجوده الان في اسواق المال
المشكله كانت انه الاستثمار في هذه
السندات مع ارتفاع اسعار الفائده للفدرالي
العوائد على سندات تايمه تكون منعكسه
فيعني كلما رفع البنك الفيدرالي اسعار
الفائده كل ما شفنا خسارات غير محققه على
هذه السندات اداره البنك ما كانت سيئه
ولكن جميع البنوك الذي استثمروا خلال
السنوات الماضيه مع اسعار فائده
منخفضه جدا ستتاثر في هذه المرحله وطبعا
اتحدث ايضا على بنود الاوروبيه
والصناديق السياديه اي مستثمر استثمر في
السمندات الخزانه الامريكيه والان عندهم
خسارات غير محققه
لا اعتقد ان البنوك المحليه يعني في دول
الخليج ستتاثر يعني نعم عندهم على محافظ
في استثمارات في سندات اوروبيه وسندات
امريكيه ولكن تاثير لا اعتقد انه سيكون
يعني ملحوظ مثل ما هو في البنوك الامريكيه
وكذلك يعني اعتقد ان في بعض البنوك
الاوروبيه كذلك
اللجنه التي شكلت لتعويض المودعين وليس
المستثمرين طبعا كيف سيكون الدفع هل هناك
يعني من من طرق او من جدوله واضحه حتى
الساعه خصوصا يعني ما زالت التفاصيل غير
واضحه
نعم وحسب اخر تصريح يعني جميع الموضوع
المودعين في هذا البنك
يحصلون على
ودائعهم وهذا يعني شيء غريب بالنسبه لي
لانه
الحسابات المضمونه حسب
للحسابات ما يصل الى 250 الف دولار فما
اقل فيعني سبب البنك لمحاوله او او البنك
محاوله
ايجاد حل واضح لجميع الموضوعين هذا طبعا
يعطيه ثقل للسوق وانا برايي ان الثقه هذه
هذه اللي ادت الى
التراجع اسواق المال اليوم في طريقه
ايجابيه
اذا مشاهدينا بعد انهيار سيليكون فالي
ترقب لفرمله اسعار الفائده وخسائر الاسواق
بالمليارات وتوقعات متباينه حول تخلي
الفيدرالي الامريكيه عن خطته خلال شهر
مارس مارس الماضي على ان يعيد العمل به
لاحقا فقدت الاسهم الماليه العالميه
465 مليار دولار من قيمتها السوقيه خلال
ثلاثه ايام مع خفض المستثمرين لانكشافهم
على المصارف عقب انهيار بنك سيليكونزالي
لكن هذا السقوط المفاجئ بوقت قياسي لمصرف
سيليكون فالي في اقل من اسبوع فتحت باب
مخاوف من تكرار سيناريو عام 2008 الاداره
الامريكيه سارعت لمحاوله تهدئه المذيعين
والمستثمرين على سلامه القطاع البنكي
واجل اجل طبعا المركزيه الامريكيه رفع سعر
الفائده لامتصاص
الانهيار وتفادي عوده التضخم لكن الخسائر
كانت فادحه وانعكست تدهورا للبورصات
وسقوطا حرا لاسهم القطاع البنكي في
البورصتين الامريكيه والاوروبيه في
المقابل مشاهدينا بعيدا عن التعقيقات
الاقتصاديه هناك بعض النصائح البسيطه التي
يستفيد منها طبعا العامه فيما يتعلق
باسعار الفائده وتجنب الاضرار الماديه
خلال الازمات الماليه فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تهاج
م
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد افاتت مصادر قضائيه
لبنانيه للعربيه بانها تعقد غدا جلسه
استجواب لحاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه امام
القاضي شربل ابو سمره في قضايا اختلاس
اموال عامه صباح غد الاربعاء مضيفه اي
المصادر ذاتها ان الجلسه ستتم في قصر
العدل في بيروت واكد المصدر نفسه انه من
المنتظر ان يحضر سلامي شخصيا للجلسه لانه
وكلائه القانونيون لم يقدموا دفوعا شكليه
بحضورهم نيابه عنه وان التحقيق معه سيكون
بحضور قادم فرنسي من ضمن وفد المحققين
الاوروبيين الموجودين اصلا في لبنان
هبوط تاريخي شهدته العمله اللبنانيه
الدولار الامريكي بات يساوي اكثر من مئه
الف ليره في ادنى مستوى طبعا تسجله العمله
اللبنانيه منذ بدء الازمه وبالمقابل جوله
جديده من الاضرابات بداتها المصارف
اللبنانيه اغلاق لابوابها امام المواطنين
التزاما طبعا بقرار جمعيه المصارف
اللبنانيه ياتي ذلك مشاهدينا بعد قرار
العوده للاضراب لحين اتخاذ التدابير
القانونيه السريعه لوضع حد لما وصفته
بالخلل في اعتماد معايير متناقضه في اصدار
بعض الاحكام التي تستنزف ما بقي من اموال
المودعين
واموال تعود لجميع المودعين وليس لبعضهم
على حساب الاخرين فوفقا للوكاله الوطنيه
للاعلام فان اضراب البنوك ياتي في الوقت
الذي تتركز فيه الانظار على الاستجواب
الذي سيخضع له حاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه
القضاء الاوروبي بصفه شاهد ازمه اقتصاديه
خانقه انعكست سلبا طبعا على المواطنين
الذين لجا بعضهم الى الانتحار لاسباب
تركوها في رسائل خاصه تتحدث عن ضيق
المعيشه فخلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
مشاهدينا سجلت ست حالات انتحار لفئات
عمريه مختلفه في عده مناطق لبنانيه فحسب
بيان لقوى الامن الداخلي تم تسجيل
حاله انتحار عام 2022 الا ان هذا الرقم
قابل للزياده حيث كان هناك بعض العائلات
التي لم تبلغ اصلا عن انتحار احد افرادها
خوفا من المجتمع
[موسيقى]
اتهم مع وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الولايات
المتحده واستراليا وبريطانيا بتدبير
مواجهه تستمر لسنوات في اسيا عبر اطلاقها
تحالف اوكوس بشان الغواصات النوويه
فلنستمع لما قالها
العالم يبني تكتلات مثل اوكوس ويطور البنى
التحتيه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في اسيا ويراهن
بجديه على مواجهه تستمر لسنوات طويله
الولايات المتحده تبذل مساعي لاخضاع دول
اسيا لارادتها هذا يجب ان يتوقف
من جهتها دعت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه الولايات المتحده واستراليا
وبريطانيا الى تنفيذ ضمانات الوكاله بشان
الالتزام بعدم زياده الانتشار النووي
عالميا وذلك بعد اعلان الخطه الامريكيه
الهادفه لتزويد استراليا بثلاث غواصات
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه كما شددت الوكاله
ايضا على ان اطراف تحالف اوكوس ملتزمه
بعدم الانتشار النووي العالمي
اذا اكبر استثمار في القدرات الدفاعيه
العسكريه في تاريخ استراليا هو مشروع شراء
غواصات تعمل بالدفع النووي الصفقات تقوم
على حصول استراليا على 8 غواصات نوويه
تدخل الخدمه في سنه 2040 على ان تكون
استراليا قادره على تصنيع غواصاتها
النوويه بحلول سنه 2050 حسب توقعات
الحكومه الاستراليه فان قيمه هذه الصفقه
سوف تتراوح بين
268 الى 368 مليار دولار حتى سنه
وافقت هنا الولايات المتحده على بيع ثلاث
الى خمس غواصات نوويه الى استراليا من
طراز فيرجينيا التي تعد احدث الغواصات في
الوصول النوويه الامريكي غواصات فيرجينيا
مشاهدينا تبلغ قيمه القطعه الواحده منها
نحو ثلاث مليارات دولار وذلك يجعلها اغلى
الغواصات النوويه في العالم تتميز بالقدره
على القيام بمجموعه كبيره من المهام خصوصا
القدره العاليه على جمع المعلومات والتجسس
وخوض الحروب المضاده للغواصات تعد اول من
يستخدم تقنيه الاستشعار الضوئي عوض
المنظار التقليدي كونها مجهزه بكاميرات
عاليه الدقه واجهزه استشعار تكثيف الضوء
والاشعه تحت الحمراء وسلاح ليزر عالي
الطاقه بقدره تبلغ 500 كيلو وات اما عن
الغواصات النوويه التي ستصنع في استراليا
في عام 2040 فستكون على طراز الغواصات
النوويه
استوت وهي الجيل الاخير من الغواصات
النوويه البريطانيه المعززه ايضا بالتقنيه
النوويه الامريكيه يطلق عليها الزاهيه وهي
اكبر واقوى غواصات هجوميه في البحريه
الملكيه البريطانيه على الاطلاق تجمع بين
اجهزه الاستشعار العاليه الحساسيه
والاسلحه الرائده عالميه
[موسيقى]
وصفت مفوضيه الدفاع في مجلس النواب
الالمانيه الاتحاديه اوضاع الجيش الالماني
في سكناته بالحاله التي يرثى لها مشيره
الى نقص الذخيره والاسلحه وتدني الخدمات
في مرافق الاقامه
الجيش الالماني ولديه القليل جدا من كل
شيء وقد كان لديه اقل من ذلك في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير العام الماضي ربما
سمعتموني اشكو من البنيه التحتيه عده مرات
لان ثكناتنا العسكريه في جميع انحاء
البلاد في حاله يرثى لها هناك نقص في
اماكن الاقامه والمراحيض والاستحمام
والخزائن والمرافق الرياضيه والمطابخ
بالاضافه الى مرافق الدعم ومخازن الذخيره
والاسلحه واخيرا وليس اخرا شبكه واي فاي
ولهذا السبب هناك حاجه ماسه للاستثمار
والتي تقدر الان بنحو 50 مليار يورو
[موسيقى]
شدد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
اعلى ان المحادثات السعوديه الايرانيه تعد
ممارسه ناجحه لتنفيذ مبادره الامن العالمي
مؤكدا على ان بلاده ستواصل مساهمتها
لتحقيق الامن في المنطقه
بغض النظر عن مدى تعقيد المشاكل والتحديات
طالما اننا ننخرط في حوار متساوي بروح
الاحترام المتبادل فسوف نجد بالتاكيد
حلولا مقبوله للطرفين كما ان الشرق الاوسط
من كل شعوب المنطقه وينبغي ان يكون
مستقبلهم في ايديهم المحادثات السعوديه
الايرانيه في بكين هي ايضا ممارسه ناجحه
لتنفيذ مبادره الامن العالمي وسنواصل
المساهمه بالرؤى والمقترحات الصينيه
لتحقيق السلام والهدوء في الشرق الاوسط
والقيام بدوري الصين كدوله مسؤوله
وفي السعوديه ايضا اعلن طيران الرياض
الناقل الجوي الوطني الجديد الذي اطلقه
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه اعلن عن اول
طلباته لاسطول الطائرات عبر شراء اثنين
وسبعين طائره بوينج وشملت الصفقه تسعه
وثلاثين طائره مؤكده مع احتماليه شراء 33
طائره اضافيه ومن ناحيه التاثير الاقتصادي
سيسهم طيران الرياض في نمو الناتج
المحاليل الاجمالي غير النفطي للمملكه
بقيمه تصل الى 75 مليار ريال واستحداث
اكثر من 200 الف فرصه عمل مباشره وغير
مباشره بحسب بيان صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه اما عن التاثير الاقتصادي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فمن المتوقع
ان توفر الصفقه ما يقارب 100 الف وظيفه
مباشره وغير مباشره وتحقق استفاده لاكثر
من 300 مورد في 38 ولايه
بما في ذلك
145 شركه صغيره
وتعد مشاهدينا هذه الاتفاقيه جزءا من
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للطيران الهادفه
لتحويل المملكه الى مركز طيران عالمي حيث
اعلنت ايضا الخطوط الجويه السعوديه عن
عزمها شراء طائرات جديده من نوع بوينج مع
خيار شراء 10 طائرات اضافيه ليصبح اجمالي
عدد الطائرات في الصفقتين 121 طائره لتكون
ضمن اكبر خمس طلبات تجاريه لاسطول
الطائرات من حيث القيمه في تاريخ شركات
بوينك وستدعم هذه الاتفاقيه اهداف المملكه
لنقل اكثر من 330 مليون مسافر وجذب 100
مليون زائر بحلول عام 2030
وهذه نظره مشاهدينا على سهم بوينج
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
يستمر في هجومه على ديسنتس لمنعه من
الحصول على اي زخم جمهوري في الانتخابات
القادمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا قبل ان اكمل
ساعود الى موضوع الطائره المسيره
الامريكيه التي اسقطت فوق البحر الاسود
حيث اصدرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بيانا
تقول فيه رصدنا طائره مسيره امريكيه صباح
اليوم بالقرب من شبه جزيره القرم وان
الطائره المسيره الامريكيه حلقت باتجاه
حدود روسيا واغلقت جهاز الاتصال اذا كان
هذا البيان الرسمي عن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تعليقا على حادثه المسيره
الامريكيه بعد طبعا البيان الامريكي الذي
اعتبر هذا التصرف غير مسؤول
بالانتقال الى ملف اخر وتحديدا الى العراق
حيث اكد رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني رغبه بلاده الجاده في انهاء
الملفات العالقه مع اربيل بشكل جذري على
حد وصفه جاء ذلك خلال لقاء السوداني برئيس
حكومه اقليم كردستان مسرور برزاني والذي
اكد من جانبه حرص اربيل على استمرار
المباحثات والمضي نحو معالجه النقاط
الخلافيه بالاضافه الى التاكيد على العمل
المشترك لحل كافه الاشكالات بين البلدين
وفقا طبعا للبيان الحكومي العراقي
يواجهوا العراق وسوريا كابوسا يتجدد كل
فتره وهو كبوس الجفاف والتصحر والتحولات
المناخيه التي طرات على مناسيب نهري دجله
والفرات في ذروه فصل الشتاء حيث لاحظ معظم
سكان المدن الواقعه على النهرين اغلب
المدن العراقيه تقع طبعا على ضفاف هذين
النهرين ومناطق شمال شرق سوريا ان مناسيب
النهرين انخفضت بشكل كبير في الاونه
الاخيره احتمال جفاف نهر الفرات وتحول نهر
دجله الى مجرد ساقيه صغيره باتت قائمه
خصوصا ان بلاد الرافدين تعد الاكثر تاثرا
بالتغيير المناخي سد الموصل الذي يقع
بالقرب من منابع نهر دجله القادم من
الجاره التركيه قد انخفضت مناسيبه الى نحو
30% مقارنه بمثل هذه الايام من العام
الماضي وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لمناسيب نهر
الفرات المسؤولين في وزاره المواد الموارد
المائيه يؤكدون ان العراق خسر 70% من حصصه
المائيه بسبب السياسات التي يمارسها كل من
تركيا وايران والى حد ما سوريا في شماليه
شرقي سوريا الذي يعد السله الغذائيه يلقي
الجفاف بظلاله هذا العام للسنه الثالثه
على التوالي مع انحصار المساحات الخضراء
الصالحه للزراعه جرائم انعدام سقوط
الامطار الكافيه منذ اكثر من شهر
[موسيقى]
الى باكستان حيث قال وزير الداخليه
الباكستانيه ان الشرطه ستعتقل رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان اليوم وستقدمه
للمحاكمه تاتي تصريحات وزير الداخليه
الباكستاني بالتزامن مع اشتباكات بين
الشرطه وانصار عمران خان خارج منزله في
مدينه لاهول شرقيه البلاد وصدرت اوامر
لعمران خان بالمثول امام قادم في اسلام
اباد يوم الجمعه للرد على اتهامات بيع
هدايا حكوميه بشكل غير قانوني تلقاها خلال
فتره رئاسته للوزراء واخفاء اصول
[تصفيق]
على الجانب الاخر لم يهدا عمران خان لبل
بدا بالتصعيد اذ وصف رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق الحكومه الحاليه
بحكومه اللصوص داعيا انصاره الى مواصله
الكفاح اذا ما تم قتله او سجنه
انا احارب معركتكم لقد حاربت طوال حياته
وساواصل ذلك لكن اذا حدث لي شيء ما ودخلت
السجن او قتلت فعليكم اثبات ان هذه الامه
ستستمر في كفاحها بدون عمران خالد فهذه
حكومه لصوص ويجب ان لا تقبلوا بذلك ابدا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسلام اباد عبد
الرحمن المزيني مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
يعني سابدا من التطورات على الارض هل
مازال مناصروا عمران خان موجودين يعني
بنفس النقطه هل ما زالت الاشتباكات دائره
كيف هي صوره من هناك
نعم حقيقه الاشتباكات امتدت لتطاع العدد
من المدن الباكستانيه الرئيسيه تحديدا مثل
كراتشي
وبيشاور
وحتى العاصمه استنبات كانت هناك مناوشات
بين الشرطه هناك حاله من الكر والفرق بين
المحتجين المغالين للرئيس رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان وقوات الامن هذه
الاحتجاجات تشتد في مناطق وتخف في مناطق
اخرى
تخف في مناطق وتشتد في اخرى حول لكن ابرز
هذه الاحتجاجات والاشتباكات كانت في محيط
منزل رئيس الوزراء السابق في مدينه لاهور
كان هناك حاله من الهدوء النسبي قبل نحو
نصف ساعه من الان قد يتطور الوضع قد تتجدد
الاشتباكات مره اخرى في ظل تصريحات وزير
الداخليه بانه من المقرر ان يتم اعتقال
رئيس الوزراء الس اليوم
اود الاشاره الى ان هناك عدد من مذكرات
الاعتقال بحق رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان لعل من ابرزها ما يتعلق بما يعرف
بقضيه الهدايا وهي اتهامات وجهت له
بالاستحواذ والانتفاع بهدايا قدمت للدوله
وقام عمران خان بالتستر عليها والاستحواذ
عليها بطريقه غير شرعيه كما تقول المحكمه
هناك ايضا قضيه تتعلق بتهديد قاضيه محكمه
جنائيه من المقرر ان يمثل عمران خان امام
المحكمه بتاريخ 18 من هذا الشهر سبق له
التخلف مرتين
اصدرت محكمه عليا او علقت محكمه عليا
مذكره الاعتقال بحقه لكن رغم ذلك لم يمثوا
العمران خان يوم امس كان من المفترض ان
يتم توجيه لائحه الاتهام ضده لكنه تخلف عن
حضور المحاكمه وهو ما حذى بالسلطات اليوم
لارسال فريق من شرطه العاصمه اسلام اباد
لاعتقاله لكن ما جرى انه عندما اقترب هذا
الفريق من مقر اقامه رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان قام انصاره
التصدي لقوات الشرطه وبدات المناوشات
بينهم تم اطلاق الائره المسيله للدموع
بالاضافه الى خراطيم المياه لتفريق
المتظاهرين
يعني كان من المقرر بحسب التصريحات
الرسميه ان يتم اعتقاله اليوم المواجهات
ما زالت دائره وطبعا يعني هناك بعض الشكوك
والخوف من ان تتوسع ما الذي سيحصل او
المتوقع ان يحصل بالساعات المقبله هل ممكن
ان يتم تعزيز قوه امنيه اكبر لفعلا القاء
القبض عليه ام يعني ستتريث القوى الامنيه
بهذا الموضوع
حقيقه يبدو ان القوى الامنيه لا تريد
استخدام القوه المفرطه لا سيما انها
تتعامل مع شخصيه سياسيه عمران خان هو رئيس
وزراء سابق وليس مطلوبا امنيا يتم
مداهمه مقر اقامته بقوات خاصه ربما مثلا
الشرطه تحاول قدر المستطاع تفريق
المتظاهرين من محيط منزل رئيس وزراء
السابق تمهيدا
للتوجه الى عمران خان وتسليم مذكره
الاعتقال له هو اتباع الاجراءات القانونيه
المتبعه هناك نقطه اود الاشاره اليها وان
الفريق القانوني لعمران خان قدم التماسا
امام المحكمه السنوات العليا من المقرر ان
تستمع
المحكمه يوم غد لطلب تمديد تمديد او ايقاف
مذكره اعتقال بحقه ربما يسعى عمران خان
وانصاره لاطاله امد هذه المواجهات الى يوم
الغد الى حين ان تفصل محكمه السنباد
العليا في الالتماس المقدم
لطالما شعبي كبير يسعى الى خلق الفوضى
القبض على عمران خان بانتظار طبعا المسار
القانوني الذي تحدثت عنه شكرا لك عبد
الرحمن اذا نجح عمران خان بحشد العدد
الكافي من الانصار
شكرا لك عبد الرحمن المزيني حدثتنا من
اسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
شعار عدنا مره اخرى واحتجاجاتنا مستمره
شهدت عده مدن ايرانيه بينها العاصمه طهران
مظاهرات جديده فوفقا لايران انترناشونال
فقد شهدت مناطق ومدن في كرج ومشهد وسننذج
وكاميران ومهبات احتجاجات صباحيه وليليه
مناهضه للنظام الايراني هذه الاحتجاجات
جاءت تلبيه لنداء نشطاء ايرانيين دعوا
لايام من الاحتجاجات اطلقوا عليها ثلاث
ليال من النار وتتزامن هذه الاحتجاجات مع
انخفاض جديد شهدته العمله الايرانيه حيث
وصل سعر صرف الدولار الواحد الى اربعه
وسبع الى 47 الف الامر الذي انعكس على
السوق كرفع رسوم مخازن الفواكه والخضار
وهو ما دفع بسائقي الشاحنات لتنفيذ اضراب
في شيراز
نذهب الان مشاهدينا الى الولايات المتحده
وايجاد صحفي للتاكد
لن اخوضا في التفاصيل الخاصه بهذه الطائره
لديها القدره على حمل الاسلحه ومره اخرى
كانت
حمله اي اس ار او استطلاع في مياه دوليه
وهذا شيء نفعله منذ فتره طويله اما فيما
يخص
الاساليب الاجراءات التي يتخذها لحمايه
طائراتنا ولا ناخذها في التفاصيل النقطه
الاساسيه هنا
هي ان
احد الطائرات ليست غير شائعه لكن مثل هذه
السلوكيات من الطيار
غير امنه
وكرم طالبه الجنرال هكر
الاستمرار بالتحاليق الامن
هل هذا التصادم كان حادثا بسابي روسيا وهل
الولايات المتحده تستجيب
نحن مستمرون بتقييم ما حصل ولكنني اعتقد
بانه وفقا
لتصرفات الطيار الروسي كان غير مهنيا وغير
امنا
واعتقد من التصرفات تعبر عن نفسها ما
شاهدناه مره اخرى
مقاتله ترمي الوقود امام هذه المسيره
وكانت قريبه جدا من الطائره الى الحد الذي
اضر بمروحيه المسيره
حسب تقييمنا فانا هذا سببه الاضرار
للطائره الروسيه ايضا وحسب معلوماتنا هي
ان هذه الطائره الروسيه حبطت اولا ان اقول
اين
ولكن مره اخرى هذا
تعبير عن التحليق غير الامن لهذا الطيار
هل ستحاله متحده استعادتي هذه المسيره
الله معلومات فيما عمليات خاصه باستعاد
فيها
هل هنالك فيديو للحادثه وهل ستطقون هذا
الفيديو
اين في البحر الاسود حصلت مع مدافور بها
من المجال الجوي الروسي
وهل قلتم
بان هذه المسيره كانت غير مسلحه انا لم
اقل اذا ما كانت مسلحه ام لا لن اخذ
بطبيعتي هذه
المهمه كانت تجري عمليه استطلاعيا
وفيما يخص المعلومات الفاصله لن اعطيكم
معلومات غير انها في مجال جوي دولي في
منطقه البحر الاسود
وبعيده عن
المجال الجوي كان الدولي
لم تقل الطائره او هل
هيلتزم بالقول بانها من نوع
التكنولوجيا حساسه
خل الجيش
حصلت عليها روسيا
هل هناك اي وصول بحريه امريكيه في المنطقه
اجراء عمليه
موجوده على هذه الطائره غير انها منصه
استطلاعيه
بسببي الاضرار كنا في موقف اضطرنا بسببه
في البحر الاسود وحسب معلوماتي في ان
روسيا لم يستعيدوا هذه الطائره ولكن فيما
يخص جهودنا لاستعادتها المعلومات
كره الشماليه والصواريخ الاستراتيجيه
كوريا الشماليه اعلنت انها
نكتفي بهذا القدر من الاجازه الصحافه بعد
حادثه اسقاط المسيره الامريكيه التي تصادم
طبعا مع الطائره الروسيه حيث اعلن بان لا
افصاح عن مهمه هذه المسيره بعدما كان
السلطات الامريكيه اعلنت قبل قليل بانها
بمهمه سلميه الان يقول بان لا افصح
ومعلومات عن مهمتها وعن اذا ما كانت مسلحه
ام لا هناك طبعا كان هناك سؤال عما اذا تم
استعاده هذه المسيره التي اسقطت في البحر
الاسود لا جواب حتى الساعه ولن يعطوا
تفاصيل عن عمليه استعادته وان كان الاصول
الامريكي هناك سيقوم باستعادتها وايضا عن
نشاط هناك تاكيد على ان مجال الجوي للبحر
الاسود هو مجال دولي وبالتالي يمكن
للطائره المسيره ان تكون هناك ولا خارق
للقواعد العسكريه الموجوده وطبعا اكد بان
الطائره تم
يعني تم رشه بالوقود مما ادى طبعا الى
اسقطه ابي العوده الى اخبار التاسعه
يعكس الهجوم العنيف الاخير الذي شنه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على
حاكم فلوريدا
احتدام المنافسه بين الرجلين كما يبرز
الهجوم مخاوف ترامب بشان احراز
تقدما لدى الناخبين الجمهوريين رغم ان
معظم استطلاعات الراي تظهر تقدم الرئيس
السابق على منافسه المحتمل لدى القاعده
الشعبيه في الحزب فلنتابع
على ما يبدو التقرير لم يضع حتى الساعه
سننتظر ام نختم
ننتظر اذا طبعا سيكون التقرير عن المنافسه
التي تحتدم بين كل من الرئيس الامريكي
ومنافس
بسخريته المعتاده من خصومه شن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب هجوما عنيفا
على حاكم فلوريدا سانتوس
في ولايه ايوا حاول خلاله ابطاء صعود نجم
ديستانتاس منافسه الرئيسي المحتمل في
الحزب الجمهوري الذي زار المدينه قبل ايام
الاستطلاع يقول ان ترامب لا يزال يتمتع
بمعدلات موافقه عاليه في قاعده الناخبين
الجمهوريين ويتفوق على الروندي سانتوس في
استطلاع تلو الاخر وانا اتغلب على جو بايد
كثيرا وهذا مهم جدا
وقبل ذلك صرح ترامب لصحافيين على متن
طائرته بانه ندم على تاييد
بانه غير مخلص وبانه كان ميتا كالكلب
مضيفا بان حياته السياسيه كانت ستنتهي لو
لم يؤيد حملته عام 2018
من الحصول على اي زخم انتخابيه والبدء
بزياده عدد مؤيديه لذلك يريد ايقافه قبل
ان يبدا
وبشان تصريحاتنا ابي الرئيس السابق مايك
بانس بان التاريخ سيحاسب ترامب على هجوم
الكابيتول اعتبرت ترامب بانس كان مسؤولا
عن اعمال العنف في السادس من يناير عام
كان من اللافته ان ترامب لم يهاجم بانس
بالحده ذاتها التي هاجم فيها رغم ان الاول
انتقده والثاني يتجاهله حتى الان وهو ما
يراه البعض مؤشرا على مخاوف ترامب بشان
حاكم فلوريدا الذي ينظر اليه على انه اخطر
منافسيه حسين الطاوضه العربيه واشنطن
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العالم
اصطدامه مقاتله روسيه بمسيره امريكيه فوق
البحر الاسود وواشنطن تلوم موسكو على
التهور
لمحاسبه المتسببين العدل الامريكي تحقق في
انهيار سيليكون فالي وخسائر الاسهم
الماليه تلامس نصف تريليون دولار
باشراف محققين اوروبيين القضاء اللبنانيه
استجوب غدا رياض سلامه في قضايا اختلاس
اموال عامه
وبعد فشل محاولتين لاعتقاله السلطات
الباكستانيه تتوعد عمران خان بالقبض عليه
قريبا وتقديمه للمحاكمه
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
ولكن طبعا اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل
ليله والان الى 360 مع الزميل صهيب صهيب
مساء الخير مساء الخير صحيح صهيب قد يختلط
الامر قليلا هذه الليله تبديل مواقع
فلديك صهيب الليل سنركز طبعا على اتفاقيه
الغواصات يبدو ان الوكاله الدوليه التقنيه
لديها مخاوف من تشارك الغواصات تكنولوجيا
الغواصات المدفوعه النوويا مع كمبيرا لان
هذا يمكن ان ينطوي على مخاطر نوويه سيكون
معنا خبير في الطاقه النوويه بعد قليل في
360 شكرا لك